[Music]
we're beginning with some breaking news
coming in from Sudan where we're getting
reports of heavy gunfire across the
capital tensions have been rising in
recent days between the Army and the
rapid support Forces paramilitary Group
let's go straight to HIPAA Morgan who
joins us live from there so Hibbert tell
us what's the situation right now with
the fighting
[Music]
well we've just received statement from
the rapid support forces detailing their
side of the story in which they say that
in soba camp where there is a military
camp both for the rapid support forces
and the middle and and the uh Sudanese
Armed Forces now the rapid support
forces say that they were attacked by
the Sudanese armed forces in the early
hours of April 15th which is today we
are hearing gunfire in the capital here
Khartoum near the vicinity of the
presidential Palace in the northern part
of the capital as well as in sober where
they started and other parts of the
capital as well so lots of confusion
here with regards to what is happening
at the moment people around the country
around the capitol can hear the gunshots
they are terrified right lots of people
have been that have not been able to
access public transport so they've been
working on foot trying to access to get
to the safety of their homes because of
the confusion I don't know if you can
hear but there is still the sound of
gunfire from the vicinity of the
presidential Palace where we're not far
from right right now lots of confusion
again Sammy with regards to what's
happening but what people do know is
that the tension between the rapid
support forces and the military has
reached its height with now direct
confrontation between the two sides not
here in the capital uh Khartoum only but
also Mary where the tension started
and just to bring together all these
little reports which are coming in it
sounds like fighting is happening in
many parts of the country right
different areas
yes and that was the concern of the
political parties of the trilateral
tripartite mechanism that has been
mediating in the talks between the Army
and the and the political parties and uh
the constant for many people really
including the International Community is
that both sides are on both sides have
troops stationed in various parts of the
country in various parts of the capital
and should it escalate between them yep
you can hear that that's the sound of
the gunfire
um just around us here in the capital of
not far from the presidential Palace and
that's the concern Sammy the fact that
they have troops in various parts of the
country in various parts of the capital
and including cities where there's
civilian lives where this where they're
residential areas so there are concerns
that there will be civilian casualties
in this battle between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army all right
and Hibbert just to confirm what you
mentioned a moment ago you mentioned
that the rsf have put out this statement
saying they're being attacked by the arm
me is that something we can confirm
though
have we had any statement from the Army
for example about what's happening
no we can't we're yet to hear from the
army with regards to what's happening
the Army has not put out a statement uh
we've tried to reach the Army for
comments that has been very difficult at
the moment to get through to them but
what we do know is that there are indeed
direct clashes between the Army and the
rapid support forces regardless of who
started it and regardless of uh of who
is responsible for the first shot the
fact remains right now Sami is that
there is direct military confrontation
between the rapid support forces and the
Army two forces again with troops and
forces spread around the capital around
the country including residential
neighborhoods and so there are concerns
that there will be civilians caught in
the crossfire between the two sides and
while you're talking bear with me for a
second here because we've got lines
dropping the Sudanese paramilitary rapid
support forces say that they've
communicated with International and
local mediators and inform them of the
situation of course it remains to be
seen what they can do at this point but
you also mentioned fighting a around the
presidential Palace is that right hibber
we can hear the gunfire Sammy where we
are right now we can't exactly see what
is happening but from the vicinity of
the presidential Palace we can hear the
gunshots we can hear this gunshots from
the northern part of the capital and
from the Twin City of the of hartum as
well which is behind us in par in other
parts of Khartoum such as Riyadh and
soba we've spoken to Residents there who
say they can hear the gunfire and they
also say they can see the smokes uh as a
result of these clashes many of them say
that they had to hide within their homes
because of these uh sudden eruption of
fighting between the two sides streets
there are a lot of confusions where
people have started to go out to start
their day uh on on this Saturday now
most of them have returned to their
homes seeking safety until we figure out
exactly how bad is it and where are the
areas most affected whether in the
capital or other cities as well
all right and as uh as well now this is
obviously a breaking news story and
developing story so bear with us hibber
because I'm getting all kinds of lines
coming in here there's a statement by
the rapid support Forces Group saying
that things kicked off today when
basically a unit of the army tried to
enter a position held by the rapid
support forces in their camp in sober
I'm just translating it from from Arabic
here so bear with me so they're saying
that that's how things kicked off
Hibbert tell us a little bit about the
importance of silver
thank you
while Silber is a military Camp it is a
it's in the the outskirts of the of the
of cap of the city hartum uh there are
military presence both for the uh rapid
support forces and the Army
military-wise though it doesn't hold
more significance than let's say
middlewe right now where uh there where
there is also fighting between the two
sides and where the tension started
um the fact is that the tensions between
the two sides any small uh uh
altercation between the two sides would
have led to what we are seeing right now
and I don't know if you can hear Sammy
but there is heavy sounds of gunfire
around uh where I am right now again and
this is the vicinity of the presidential
Palace we do know that the Army did
block the roads leading to the
presidential Palace just about 15 to 20
minutes ago but there are there have
been the presence of Rapid support
forces uh inside the presidential Palace
as well because again the head of the
rapid support forces is the Deputy head
of the sovereignty Council that's the
governing body here in Sudan while the
head of the army General Abdel is the
head of the sovereignty Council so lots
of confusion here with regards to what's
happening right now what we do know
again is that there is fighting between
the two sides in sober in marawi where
tension has been at its peak for the
past 24 to 48 hours and despite the fact
that we've heard statements from both uh
or rather from mediators saying that
both the head of the Army and the head
of the rapid support forces are ready to
de-escalate the situation uh just hours
after hearing from mediators that the
army that the head of the Army is ready
to de-escalate we're hearing gunfire
around the capital hartum and berowee
maybe it's a good time as well to put
this into context this tension started
over the question of integrating the rsf
into the army right
that's if you're looking for a specific
point uh to to to to to mark this
tension but in reality tensions have
been ongoing between the rapid support
forces and the Army way longer than that
Sammy uh we've seen uh months after the
military Takeover in October 2021 when
we heard from the head of the rapid
support forces uh describing that
military takeover as a mistake which
lets you down to further political
turmoil while the head of the army who's
the head of the sovereignty Council uh
said that this was a necessity that
military takeover was a necessity
because Sudan was in a political turmoil
and was on the edge as per his words so
obviously months after that takeover the
two were at odds on how to run uh the
the post military takeover period and
then came the issue of negotiating with
the political parties both had different
views with how to negotiate with the
parties how to uh to to come to an
agreement for a new transitional
government and now with this talks
between the political parties and and
the military they came the issue of the
security sector reform the military we
wanted the rsf to fall under its command
while the rsf wanted to fall under the
command of a civilian government then
there's the issue of integration how
long that should take and the ranks and
and files of the offices within the rsf
and how they should be assessed and
reintegrated into the army so all of
this just simply added to the already
existing tension between the rapid
support forces and the Army and which it
looks like today on Saturday has reached
its peak with gunfire between the two
sides and just help our International
audience to understand the difference
between the Army and this rsf rapid
support forces and how they're led by
two figures who are independent of each
other to some degree
thank you
well you have to look at the origin of
the rapid support forces the rapid
support forces was officially
established in 2013 but they've been
fighting in the western region of Darfur
Way Beyond before that 10 years before
that in fact uh when they were fighting
against the rebel forces alongside the
Army now in 2013 they became an official
uh fighting group I again I don't know
if you can hear how long this is
obviously within the this is within the
presidential Palace that we can
definitely confirm because of the
vicinity and how loud it is and it looks
like a heavy heavy gunfire between the
two sides but then again let's return to
the rapid support forces they have been
established officially in 2013 to be
under the head of the intelligence back
then but around 2018 they were placed
under the commander of the Armed Forces
who was president Bashir uh back then in
2018. in 2019 when he was deposed the
head of the rapid support forces became
the deputy head of the sovereignty
Council while the commander-in-chief of
the army became the commander of the
sovereignty Council so the that's that's
the difference between the two sides the
rsf is a paramilitary group that was set
up to fight the Insurgency in the
western region of Darfur they also
played a role in attacking the Satan uh
the protection in front of the Army
headquarters in June 2019 and the
military has been around obviously since
in the independence of sudanistan
institution that has been around
I just want to make sure you are in a
safe place because we can definitely
hear the gunfire erupting around you
questions
uh yeah I I I we would say again we are
within the vicinity of the presidential
Palace and we can hear the gunshots uh
and it looks like it is escalating we
heard it earlier but now it's getting uh
more and more
um
let me ask you this question you've
mentioned that there was an ex you can
confirm there's some explosions going on
around the presidential Palace
does that raise a question mark about
the safety of uh yes sir
or the faith of
what can you tell us about that
well uh General's official residence is
military I just heard that rounds have
been fired around if you need to go and
take cover let's not keep you exposed
no no we will be all right I guess uh
when I disappear from the screen that's
when you should be concerned uh but yes
I know the head of the Armed Forces
residence is actually within the uh Army
of the headquarters of the army so he
wouldn't uh normally be at the
presidential Palace at the moment but
the forces from both sides forces from
both sides the rapid support forces and
the Army do have their troops within the
presidential Palace again that's because
while General abdul-fatah al-burhan is
the commander of the Armed Forces uh
General Muhammad hamdananda the head of
the Iraq and support forces is the
Deputy head of the sovereignty Council
so uh the the there will be the the the
the presence of troops from the rapid
support forces and the military inside
the presidential Palace is expected
all right I think we're going to leave
it there thanks so much Chiba we'll come
back to you later
all right joining us by phone from
Khartoum is the spokesman of the
Sudanese professionals Association good
to have you with us so does this look to
you from what you've been able to verify
that this is the feared clash between
the rapid support forces and the Army
going on
yeah yeah actually the troops of the
Army attack attempt for the rsf today
morning
in sober that is called the uh sober
Camp base where there is the art of uh
forces and it was in the statements of
the earth that a huge troop of the army
attacked the base of the rsf without any
um
uh president or without any preceding
awareness or preceding
alarm that they are coming and they
attacked them with the many types of
guns uh so I think this is a Muslim
Brotherhood
inside the Army because two days ago
since the day before yesterday they
invased uh or they were a big presence
of the Muslim Brotherhood
in the Army under the name of the
reserve forces they were seen in a in
Army machines in cartoon actually and
they are carrying green sticks a young
guys getting green sticks the same that
was there in the disruption of the
sitting area near the Army headquarter
in hartum in
2019 before in the beginning of the
Revolution and at the same green sticks
that were used by the Muslim Brotherhood
where they attacked the bar association
house uh one uh one year ago in this uh
after the 25th October cool so I think
this is a big move from the Muslim
Brotherhood
people or arms inside the Army to attack
the rapid support forces because the
because of their position from the
framework agreement and the final
political process we know that the
Sudanese professionals Association was
involved in the mediation efforts it
sounded before this escalation of
violence like a resolution was coming
together we heard statements from both
tagalo and abdefattar talking about
taking steps to resolve things what went
wrong yeah
is because of the Muslim Brotherhood
inside inside the army they don't want
the things to go down they want to get
escalated actually because this is the
last resort
for uh this is the final battle for the
Muslim Brotherhood to come uh to the
power they will not allow any uh final
political process uh or any final
agreement to be but the Army is
controlled by by
not by Muslim Brotherhood or any other
factions surely if if Army units are
mobilizing this is indicative of
having some control in the situation
25th October is hidden is hiding the
Muslim Brotherhood behind it is the
Muslim Brotherhood in the Army you know
since uh the al-Bashir regime the Army
was much uh invaded by the Muslim
Brotherhood actually and even even the
rapid support forces but much more the
army so uh
allows the return back of most if not
all the Muslim Brotherhood in many
aspects of life in the Ministries in the
Army and even the people who were
dismantled by the by the 30 June uh
Muslim Brotherhood regime dismantling
committee were back in the show so they
get more strength their money came back
to them and they gained again into the
power so uh this school 21st October was
hiding the Muslim Brotherhood
returned back so whenever there is let
me jump in where does this leave the
transition process from military rule to
civilian we know that there was tension
between the rsf and
the Army over some of the posts Like
Chief of Staff who becomes Chief of
Staff does it go to a civilian exactly
to fall on the civilian oversight or
remain with the military
uh what's happening since the security
sector reform workshop and during the
statements of both the Army and the rsf
which showed clearly that the rsf is
with
the idea on the opinion of their
democratic transition and the retail of
a civilian government leading the
country and the civilian leadership
should lead the security sector reform
but the Army was against that the Army
was against the devoted to transition
although they declare in their
statements they are with the Democracy
but they refuse for the civilian
government and Leadership to lead the
SSR and that is the usual that's
happening in the demotic transition so
that statement and that position from
the Army it showed clearly that the
Muslim Brotherhood in the Army are not
agreeing for security sector reform and
for civilian government to come back and
democratic transition to have a pathway
into the country and they used the Army
and their presence in the Army as their
last resource over the last way to uh to
come back to the show and to get the
leadership of the country
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much for your thoughts on that let's go
uh
some cartoon airport I think there is
something going there
all right thank you for your thoughts on
that we're looking at live pictures
coming in right now from Sudan you can
see pictures coming in from madawat
that's where clearly something is on
fire and reports coming in at least from
the side of the rapid support forces
talk about how
they have been attacked by the Sudanese
Army units they refer to an incident in
the area in a camp in subah coming under
attack this morning by what they say
aggressive units from the army that
began firing heavy and light arms on
them and they're calling for
international
condemnation of this now I believe we do
have here a Morgan with us she joins us
live from Sudan so Heba just give us a
feeling now of we're looking at live
pictures coming in from Ottawa and some
things clearly on fire it looks like
this is a situation which is continuing
to escalate right across the country
right
yes indeed I mean if people were hoping
that it would end in a few minutes and
uh the sounds of gunfire getting heavier
and heavier and uh especially again
within the vicinity of the presidential
Palace and now uh from what we
understand from sources uh uh around the
residents of the Deputy head of the
sovereignty Council and the head of the
rapid support sources uh General
Muhammad as well as within the uh the
guest house which is the resident of
General abilkata the fact that the
fighting has reached those areas then
things have escalated very quickly
um uh here in the capital the streets
have become
semi-uh and advocated people have been
seeking the safety of their of their
homes
um the roads to some of the uh the
bridges to some of the uh to the Capital
One of Them you understand has been uh
blocked by the rapid support forces
um we understand again that uh there is
fighting in soba in the area of uh Jabra
as well and we know that fighting in
marawi uh army base where the tensions
have started is ongoing so things don't
look to be coming down despite the fact
that there were statements um from
mediators that both the head of the
rapid support forces and the head of the
army say that they want to de-escalate
the situation uh to avoid this kind of
situation
all right we're getting reports here
about rsf forces the rapid support
forces deploying on the tarmac of
heartum
um airport then these are pictures we're
playing pictures right now here but let
me talk you through what we're playing
on the on the screen here we're playing
pictures latest pictures showing the
deployment of what looks like military
personnel a little hard to say just
based on looking at the pictures who
exactly they are but the reports talk
about the rsf deploying at the tarmac of
the airport in hartum can you tell us
anything about that hibber
while cartoon International Airport is
the major airport in the country and
should the rsf have taken over the time
again they've expected to be taken over
the airport and and they have been
concerned over over that as well we do
know that earlier on the Army did try to
deploy to that uh vicinity
um again this all started over an
airport to the airport in merui in
Northern Sudan so uh if if the rsf have
indeed deployed and taken over the area
International Airport then this would be
something major but again it's very hard
to get something out of the army at the
moment they seem to be more busy in uh
engaging with what's going on rather
than answering their phones which is
understandable but again the situation
has been very tense people do want to
hear just like they heard from the rapid
support forces about them being attacked
and so but they also want to hear from
the Army to figure out to figure out
exactly what happened and what is going
on in the country
and let me also bring us up to speed
hibber as you're talking we're getting
reports saying all roads to the Sudanese
Capital have now been blocked and all
roads to the presidential Palace have
been blocked so clearly this is an
escalating situation we're looking at
the latest pictures which came in you
can see the smoke billowing overhead
over buildings in the capital Khartoum
give us an idea of the relative strength
of the rsf how much muscle so to speak
do they have
well uh the RS of exact fighting Forest
has not been disclosed by the rapid
support forces we do know that it ranges
somewhere according to experts between
80 to 100
000 but this is estimation and that's
because they've continued to recruit
they've continued to train they've
continued to graduate forces especially
after the head of the rapid support
forces became the deputy head of the
sovereignty Council so it's not exactly
clear how many uh officers and how many
soldiers they have what we do know is
that they do have bases and camps around
the country ever since becoming the
deputy head of the sovereignty Council
General Mohamed hamdananda gloves forces
became stationed in further part of the
country part where uh previously he his
courses were not present so this is
Raising concerns that again because it's
starting it started here in the capital
it's happening in marawi what about the
other parts of the country places like
Darfur which is already revealing from
two decades of Civil War place is like
the East which has been very volatile
and very fragile due to conflict and
tribal tensions and where there are
forces of the rapid support forces as
well as the Army the Sudanese Army so
all of this is Raising concerns uh
because both sides are armed both sides
have forces both sides are are stationed
around the country uh they are concerned
that this one will take some time before
it dies down and that they will be
civilian casualty
as you're speaking hippo we're looking
at pictures also coming in from marawi
that of course is one of the hot spots
in this tension talk us through what
you're hearing about developments there
we can see a lot of smoke billowing Over
the Horizon there too
what we do know is that just moments
after the fighting started in soba
between the rapid support forces and uh
and the Sudanese Armed Forces uh marui
as well uh fighting father there as well
now Mary has been at the center of
attention between the two sides uh for
uh for for three days now and that's
because in the early hours of Wednesday
troops from the rapid support forces uh
moved towards the army base and the
airport in marawi and stations
themselves there more than 100 cars of
uh of from the rapid support forces
station and setting up a base camp near
the Army and that is what heightened the
already existing tensions between the
two sides now uh for the past uh when
that happened on Wednesday the Army
requested the rapid support forces to
withdraw from their new set of positions
that did not happen in fact we heard
from the commander of the Infantry in
marawi the armed the Army the Army
Commander from um
there were more reinforcements that have
for the rapid support forces in meowing
and uh that that they're fighting here
uh happening right now in what do we
shows that the situation in which many
people on many sides have hoped uh would
be would would die down and would not
lead to a full-on conversation uh is not
happening and there's now a full-on
confrontation between the two sides and
uh their concerns about the civilians
who will be caught up in the middle
we're getting lines as well talking
about how fighting is now Broken Out
close to the headquarters of the
Sudanese rapid support forces or rsf in
the Sudanese capital
is this the place where the leader of
the rsf Muhammad
also known as hametti would normally be
based
well it at the moment again because of
the tension between the two sides I mean
you can't confirm or whether they were
actually in their residential areas or
not normally he would be and his uh in
his residence and his residence is not
far from the airport not far from the uh
home and the residents of the head of
the Armed Forces General Abdul Fida
al-buhan so under normal circumstances
you'd find behind uh in his residence
which is within the Army Headquarters
you find the head of the rapid support
forces in his residence not far from the
residents of the commander of the army
and you would see their forces stationed
around each other talking to each other
dealing with each other normally because
they were at some points allies and and
partners including uh in the overthrow
of President Ahmed Bashir in the
military Takeover in October 2021. they
were partners and and things were normal
between them but after that is when the
tensions began so again we can't firm
whether the head of the rapid support
forces was at his residence at the time
of or right now when the fighting has
started but there have been a lot of
tensions over the past 24 to 48 hours so
it would not be surprising if both have
not been at their residence because
they're expecting something like this to
happen
are we hearing anything from either
the head of the army or from Muhammad
hamdan de gallo the head of the rsf at
this point
we haven't heard from any inside yet so
we haven't heard from the rapid support
forces we haven't heard from uh we from
the head of the rapid support forces
rather or from the head of the army we
have heard from the media team of the
rapid support forces detailing what they
say was an attack on their base in Copa
which is how they started whether that
is exactly what happened or whether they
had a different story to this uh to how
it started that that is something we're
yet to hear but what we do know Sammy is
that regardless again of how it started
this is now something that has spread
across the capital in umdurman the trend
city of artum in the northern part of
kharsum uh that's cartoon North across
the bridge around the vicinity of the
airports around the vicinity of the Army
Headquarters and the residents of both
the head of the rsf and the head of the
army so this has escalated to Way Beyond
just that single army base where
everything as it started
and just give us an idea here as we try
to understand what's happening and by
the way I should point out to viewers
we're looking at live pictures coming in
well momentarily that that's hard too my
belief but a moment ago we had split box
showing multiple
locations going on around the country
there we go so on the right hand of your
screen you're looking at live pictures
from Khartoum on the left hand of your
screen you're looking at pictures coming
in from middlewe that's in the north of
Sudan both areas well two of several
areas where getting pictures uh where
we're getting reports of fighting
haven't broken out of course we're
hearing about fighting in other places
too and amongst other places this is
clearly a situation which seems to be
getting out of control right across the
country but Hibbert hopefully you're
still there and can hear me give us an
idea of how much control
either both of these men have whether
it's hamiti on the one hand the rsf or
general Abdel how much cohesiveness is
there within these forces how much
control do they have over units earlier
I speaking to a guest who was suggesting
that you know these are factions within
the Army trying to start trouble you
know how much cohesiveness is there
within the structure of these military
forces
well let's first of all take a look at
the structure of the rapid support
forces again established in 2013
officially but they have been fighting
uh a decade prior to that in the uh in
the war in there for uh fighting the
rebel groups in that area in that region
um they were largely set up from the
border guards from the Arab tribes that
were armed by the uh by the Sudanese
government back then and um they don't
have the same command and structure as
the uh as the Army then when you look at
the Army uh they're an institution uh
for you to get into to become an officer
in the Army you have to go through
Military Academy you have to go through
three years of trainings and and you
basically have to climb up the ranks now
and that was that was one of the issues
between the rsf and the and the Army
when it came to integration the fact
that in the Army you have to go you have
to climb through the ranks it could take
years and it uh it comes down to your
achievements in the Army one of the
hours that it comes down to tribal
affiliations ask for experts and it
comes down to the battle default but not
the military academy that you've gone
through so that is the difference
between the two institutions um or this
or or the two forces
um when it comes to cohesiveness we've
seen the Army repeatedly
um showing some kind of showing that
they're United when it comes to uh to
issues dealing with the country when it
came to the Takeover when it came to
overthrowing the Bashir in 2019 and then
you have the rsf uh they seem to be
again largely on based on their on their
tribal affiliations and that is why as
for many people who have been studying
the rsf when complex erupt in Darfur it
takes some time for her to have down
because of the rapid support versus the
solution to their tribals
um to their tribes there in the region
so two different institutions different
makeup but both powerful both armed both
spread across the country and now both
fighting each other
and it doesn't look like it's a battle
that would um end in in in a day or two
and that's again because the Earth that
has grown uh over the past few years
especially since the head of the rff
became the deputy head of the rapid
support forces
all right so we just crossed 8 30 GMT a
few minutes ago maybe it's a good time
take a little breather and let's bring
viewers up to speed with what's
happening in hartum in Sudan right now
so reports started to trickle in about
half an hour ago or so of fighting
haven't broken out we're looking at live
pictures you can clearly see smoke there
does look like trouble is brewing in the
capital of
reports talk about
and this is of course a claim a
statement coming in from the rapid
support forces saying that one of their
units was attacked in an army camp in
Sober by the Sudanese Army that's of
course the statement by the rsf that's
their side of the story we can't confirm
that at this point but their side of the
story is the Sudanese Army moved to
attack rsf forces in suburb very quickly
we've got reports of fighting breaking
out in other areas right across Sudan
Khartoum and Murray I think we can bring
in some pictures now of murui in the
north of Sudan
there we go you can clearly see there it
does look like there's trouble going on
a lot of black smoke billowing out
and again the reports there is that
there's fighting going on close to
important installations around merway
and more reports coming in from Khartoum
saying fighting has reached the
presidential Palace
fighting has reached the headquarters of
the rsf the Sudanese rapid support
forces
these are obviously very key
areas in the power structure of this
country
airbases we had reports of the
deployment of rsf forces on the tarmac
of Khartoum Air Base airport and then we
can see pictures coming in that does
appear to show some kind of movement of
military personnel across the tarmac
there
and a call a statement by the rsf
calling for local and international
condemnation of the Sudanese Army
we have not heard from either the head
of the army personally himself
or personally from the head of the rsf
General
Muhammad hamdan de gallo also known as
hamiti
all right let's see if we can
let's let's bring in Heber Morgan again
she is
following this situation for us we saw
you up on the roof moments ago here but
thank you for bringing us
the this update in very
challenging difficult circumstances
what is the big picture here of where
this leaves the transition process right
this was supposed to be the big story of
Sudan this year was it transition away
from years and Decades of military rule
towards some kind of Civilian rule
well it depends on uh on how optimistic
you were about Sudan the fact that again
that there were tensions between the
rapid support forces and the Army was
something that many people who have been
observing who've done many people who
have been involved in Sudan uh knew
about it in fact there was even a
warning from the back from then prime
minister Abdullah that should the rapid
support forces and the Army not be
integrated and their issues sorted then
they will pose a challenge to Sudan's
transition so even way back in 2019 the
rsf and the rapid and the Sudanese armed
forces were causing concerns because
there were two two armed groups higher a
high up positions strong forces spread
around the country and obviously two
different chains of commands so that was
Raising concerns now yes there was
supposed to be a transitional government
Fund in April there was supposed to be
an agreement of a Handover of power from
the military both the rsf and the Armed
Forces to civilian government led by
political parties who will then nominate
their own prime minister that's what was
supposed to happen now obviously the
fact that there is fighting between the
two sides
um and that the issue of security sector
reform has not been resolved then the
odds of them actually coming down
signing agreement is not going to happen
anytime soon in fact
should the rsf uh be victorious in this
case then there may be renegotiating the
terms of those agreements with the
political parties now if the Army on the
other hand is the one that comes out
victorious in this battle between the
two sides then they also will
renegotiate the terms of that uh handing
over of our sustain government between
them and political parties so uh again
regardless of of who uh is going to come
out uh the winner in this in this battle
between the two the fact that is this
has halted the political uh process this
has resulted in uh in a delay of a new
period of transition to Sudan in fact
now I don't think uh the trilateral
mechanism the tripartite mechanism which
has been negotiated or rather
facilitating the talk between the
parties and the Army would be able to
bring up any any talks of uh of uh of uh
sorry we've just seen the Army moving
around uh here in on Mile Street here in
the capital of Arizona but yeah so uh
having them discuss the issue of of a
transition right now is something that
is out of question in fact the the talks
right now would probably focus on trying
to de-escalate the situation trying to
end the fighting trying to get those two
sides to sit down and negotiate rather
than uh for fighting out on the
Battleground and in residential areas
which could potentially lead to civilian
um loss of life
as you're talking hippo we're looking at
pictures coming in on the right hand of
the screen we've got pictures coming in
from Khartoum on the left hand murawee
clearly there does seem to be trouble
you can see the smoke over the capital
heartum and now
in middle in the north of Sudan and we
understand
hibber that there was supposed to be a
new transitional Constitution that was
supposed to be new steps going on
this year and in April
I guess all of that now there's a huge
question mark on all of that process
so the the fact that again uh that's one
side that is supposed to be signing an
agreement or rather two sides that we're
supposed to be signing an agreement uh
are right now and all of each other and
fighting with each other militarily and
not just verbally like it was before
then obviously that kind of puts the uh
the the issue of transitional government
transitional uh Constitution and all
that on the back burner for the time
being and the Focus right now from uh in
all the bodies here were those who
haven't facilitating uh the target
between the parties those who have been
mediating and the political parties
themselves the focus would mostly be on
trying to solve this current situation
that is unfolding and which is direct
confrontation between the rapid support
forces and the Army and they would try
to turn it into
um into into mediation between the two
sides so that at least uh there would be
some kind of stability that has taken
Sudan from just in a political turmoil
to now um full-on military battle and
and a security the issue there are
concerns of what is going to happen not
just in the capital of Arizona but it
goes beyond that Mary where uh where
things are unfolding as well there are
four which is already volatile from the
years of war and the East which is
already facing tribal tension so there
are concerns right now with all of the
things going on
um what is going to happen and
definitely the issue of forming a
transitional government signing a
transitional Constitution having a
transitional legislative assembly that
won't be in the talks anytime soon
all right thanks so much hibbous do stay
with us I'm sure we're going to come
back to you let's bring in though now
Muhammad Ahmed he's a journalist and
conflict Zone analyst joins us from
hartum good to have you with us is this
now a battle of survival between these
two military units
uh yes it's